- What up?
(crowd cheering)
Phoenix, how we doing?
I am glad that you are here.
Please, sit.
I am glad you're here.
- [Audience Member] I love you, Gary.
- I love you, back, bro.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you so much, let's get in to it.
So, look, I think the thing
that inspires me this morning
as we are now, clearly, in to late 2018,
obviously, we ate a bunch
of turkey the other day,
the holidays are upon
us, with everyone's going
to get into that mindset and very
quickly, it's going to be 2019.
By the way, it's cold as fuck in here.
(audience laughing)
Jesus, people like getting
blankets and shit, fuck!
Jesus, and, I was born
in the Soviet Union,
so, this shit feels good,
but, man, it's cold.
Anyway, here's the important thing,
and, I think whether you're 18 or 81,
wherever you are in your career.
You're pumped, you're doing,
financially well, but, you're not happy.
You're happy but you're not
financially where you're at,
when I look at this many people
the thing that runs through my mind,
is, what is the common
denominator, in this room
that over 30 minutes,
or so, I can bring value
to the most amount of people in this room
and, it comes down to timing.
To me, on the cusp of 2019,
the biggest thing that's
running through my mind, very
simply, that matters
to every single person
in this room, is this device.
This is a big deal, and, what it is
is it's a representation
of something even bigger,
which is this internet thing
is bigger then people realize.
And, what's happening in
our culture, right now,
because of the political climate
and, many other factors
is, I think, the majority
of people in this room
and the majority of people
in this country, and the
majority of people in this world
are looking at the downside
and the negativities
and the cynicism around the internet
without realizing social
media isn't changing us;
social media is exposing
who we, actually, are.
More importantly, it gets
to the bigger punch line,
which is, if this is 1948 or 1978 or 1998
and not 2018, we would not
have the ridiculous opportunity
that this brings to the table.
For me, the one thing
I know whether you're
a real estate investor, a politician,
you sell underwear, you
want to be a personal brand,
you have a cocoa drink, you want
to sell fucking wooden frames, I know.
(audience murmuring)
You selling wooden frames?
(audience laughing)
I know that regardless
of what you do here,
B to B, B to C; whether you
have 13 year old customers
you're tryna sell things to, like slime,
or 88 year olds that
you're trying to force
into your retirement home,
versus somebody else's,
that whether it's Facebook
or Instagram or YouTube
or LinkedIn, email, text
messaging, pre-roll YouTube ads,
Instagram stories, influencer marketing,
that the great under priced,
the great under priced
opportunity, in our society,
is within seven to 15 platforms
that are apps, on the mobile device.
The biggest thing that I'm fascinated by,
is the amount of people
in this room's ability
to say not my customer, not my industry,
not my demo, without recognizing how,
unbelievably, under
priced the attention is.
And, when I say under priced attention,
I stand here today for
many different reasons,
mainly, on the back of very good parenting
and, circumstance of not being born here,
but, no question, my timing
of joining my dad's
liquor store, coinciding
with email and Google AdWords
being under priced attention
is a reasons that I'm so passionate
this morning, in Phoenix,
to get people to wake up,
and, actually go all in
on the things that you've-
how many people here have
consumed my content, somewhat?
Raise your hands.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, for that group, I'm
actually way more concerned
for that group, than the people in here
that aren't here for me, and
have never heard any of this,
because for the group that
has consumed my content,
my concern is that the
repetitive nature of me trying to
desperately, at all
costs, without interest
in monetizing you, to go into
these channels and get yours.
That you don't realize how real it is,
that it's become passive noise.
Yeah, I get it Facebook ads work,
yeah I get it, you know work hard
I get it but, reality is,
here's what's upsetting me.
The thing that I've
been the pied piper for
for the last half decade is
starting to slip a little bit.
Like Facebook isn't as easy
as it was 24 months ago.
And, by the way I just said that sentence
and hundreds of faces
just shook their heads
which means they felt the effects
of Facebook ads 24
months or 36 months ago,
and, they're starting to realize,
they're not converting as
well or it's costing more
to get the same, or the organic reach,
I think all of us know
the organic reach collapsed
three four years ago.
And, how many people,
here, are marketing, or,
actively, using Instagram,
raise your hand?
So, for all those hands that are up,
I'm sure you're starting to pay attention
that even over the last
three or four weeks, feels
like something's starting to happen
'cause the organic reach is
starting to soften just enough
that it's getting on people's radars,
which reminds me a whole lot
of what started happening
when Google AdWords prices went up.
When my email list started
looking at 70 percent open rates
instead of 80, and, then on to 60,
and, then to 50, and, then to 40.
My friends, we are sitting,
right now, at this time,
in the white heat moment of
social networks controlling
a stunning majority of peoples'
attention and, it's going
to go away and then
there'll be another thing.
For you to sit here,
and not take advantage
of the current state of the internet,
when it's in your face, if
you're here this morning,
this is-- is it Wednesday?
Is today Wednesday?
You know, like what the
fuck are you doing here
on a Wednesday morning?
(audience laughing)
I assume, it would make
a lot of sense for me,
if you're sitting in this audience,
I assume you came here, and
spent you're time and money,
to extract value, to do something
that you want to happen in your life.
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- Right?
And, there's only two ways that gets done.
There's the mental part,
and, then there's the tactical part.
It's real simple, most people
play in the middle when
the reality is is if you're
not all the way over here,
and, if you are not blindly, and this
is what an entrepreneur or
an operator needs to be,
if you are not right here,
this morning and you are,
blindly, optimistic
about the opportunities
in front of you, you are vulnerable.
And, do not mix the word
optimism with delusion.
I didn't say if you're blindly delusional,
if you're delusional, you're fucked.
(audience laughing)
But, if you're cynical or pessimistic,
or, if you're gonna listen
to me when I go all the way
over here, because that's the mindset
or, if you're over
here, and you're like me
and others, and you're also
a hundred percent practical,
and, you understand how to,
actually, execute and you,
actually, do the work,
if you're not in those two
places; you're vulnerable.
And, you came here this morning, only
to check the box on one of the two things.
And, to me, the thing on the left,
I have to be contextual.
I know that Tony's gonna speak.
I know that Robert's gonna speak.
Listen, I'm thrilled to talk
to you about why optimism
and mindset and positivity
and, all that stuff
is a hundred percent, it just is.
If you decided when you woke up
that Facebook ads don't
work, they don't work.
So, for me that's cool, but,
honestly, in the limited
time that I have with you,
I want to go practical with you,
which is like Instagram story ads,
you can google it, I
don't need a fucking chart
there's doesn't need to be a deck,
I'm not gonna draw some fucking
pictures on a white board.
It's called Google.
You have it in your
fucking hand, right now.
(audience laughing)
So, if you don't know
what I'm about to say,
mentally, remind yourself, and,
if you're not good at that,
take a note right now, on
your iPad or your phone,
you should be running Instagram story ads
for your business.
Why? Because they're grossly under priced.
Why? Because hundreds of
millions of people look
through them every single day
and, are paying attention.
And, more people are not buying it, yet,
'cause they don't know how good it is.
It's called supply and demand.
You're job is not to just buy them,
you have to figure out
what picture and video
to put in front of there,
that compels the person
to do whatever the hell you want.
Vote for you for the PTA president,
or, give you 730 bucks for
your magical fucking berries.
(audience laughing)
I kinda want to leave, now.
(audience cheering)
I kind of do, I'll tell you why.
It was funny why that just
happened to me in my body,
I'm like that's it.
Like life is so simple, who ever was best
at radio content and advertising
grew in the 30s and 40s.
Whoever was best at television
commercials and TV shows
in the 50s, 60s, 70s, 80s, 90s, 2000s,
they grew, and, they won.
Whoever is best at Facebook,
Instagram, YouTube,
LinkedIn, Twitter, today, is winning.
(audience clapping)
That was a shitty ass clap.
(audience laughing)
And, let me tell you why
it's a shitty ass clap.
Because, to be great at the things
that just came out of my mouth, is hard.
It sounds great that you're gonna start
an Instagram account, and take a picture
of you taking a fucking hike,
and, your business is gonna explode.
(audience laughing)
The problem is, that's
not what happens, is it?
There's a lot of people here,
how many people here
want to be an influencer
or a personal brand in their
industry, raise your hands?
Raise it high.
So, here's what bugs the shit out of me.
When 30 to 50 percent of the
hands in this room just went up
the amount of people who
just posted something
on Instagram, yesterday,
had nine people comment,
but, they didn't reply to them,
because they're more
worried about how many likes
they're gonna get or how
many followers they get
from the post, not the actual nine people
that give a shit about them,
is why 99 percent of you,
will never achieve it.
(audience clapping)
It's true, and, I appreciate
you for clapping first, sir,
with the glasses, I saw you.
And, for me, for me, that's
the most important part.
And, for the same reason
I saw that gentleman who,
actually, started the
whole clap in this room
it's the reason I stand up here, today.
I spent my life reading your comments
on Facebook, Instagram,
Twitter, and, email.
That's how I have the insights, to create
the next thing, because
you're giving me the feedback
of what's working and
not working, for you.
The audacity of businesses and people
in 2019, in putting out content,
but, then disrespecting their audience
'cause the only thing they care about
is will their audience
give them what they want,
likes, follows, money, is
the reason it's so hard.
(audience clapping)
My friends, if you leave Phoenix, today,
with anything, when you
go home, understand this:
if you are not producing
content, for the internet,
you are leaving an incredible
opportunity on the table,
and, your competitors have
started the process to hurt you.
Now, producing content on the internet is,
extremely, interesting,
because, so many people look at
certain people and decide
that's the only way.
Many people are dominating
content and internet
without ever producing
one video in their lives,
because they're tremendous writers.
Others are self conscious to
put camera in front of them,
but, they're great with their voice,
so, they're killing it in podcast form.
If you leave with anything
please, don't be like me,
in the way that I produce content.
Be like me in the way
that I deploy self awareness
of what I'm good at,
and, then, triple down
on it, to produce it.
You might be great at drawing,
communicate like that.
You might be great at just random thoughts
and, recording it on memo, on your phone
and, you can post that.
You might be great on camera, and,
honestly, much like movies and television,
if you are great on video, it's good.
It carries weight.
But, please, leave
here, and, look yourself
in the rear view mirror,
or, when you get home,
and, ask yourself: how do I communicate?
And, start communicating.
The trick, the unlock, the
place that you will hear
an enormous amount of
pontificating, for me, in 2019,
will be around the volume of content,
that you produce, for the 10 platforms.
Over the last year, what has become,
unbelievably, obvious to me,
that works for me, for
thousands of other people,
and, the brands that
are winning, in society,
the businesses that are
growing, the one correlation
that's just black and white,
to me, is volume of creative.
How many times do they
post quality content?
How much influencer
marketing, how many articles,
white papers, podcasts, videos?
Way the world is working
with internet content,
there is so much content,
you could never over saturate
the market, even if you made 90 pieces
of content a day, about yourself.
But, this is why I went
over here as I'm talking.
The interesting part of why most
of you are not producing enough content,
has a hell of a lot more to
do with this, than with this.
We are crippled, by
other peoples' opinions.
You're not posting 'cause
you want shit to be perfect.
Why do you want it to be perfect?
Because you're fucking insecure.
(audience laughing)
You know why, because
it just ruins your day
when fatpants86 leaves a comment
and, says that you're stupid, right?
You're just super sad
when you post something,
and, you're used to getting
89 likes but, this one got 62.
I have become, outrageously, fascinated
by something over the
last two years, which is:
oh my God, the majority of
people live their lives based
on other peoples' opinions.
Whether it's their parents, older sibling
or, even worse the current
state, the anonymous person
in their YouTube comments.
(audience laughing)
That sucks, and, so
over the last two years,
especially, the last year,
I'm trying to figure out,
what is this, and, how
do I speak about this,
in a world, where I know the majority
of the reasons you came here, today,
can be solved by your
ability to produce content
on seven websites for real, for real;
why were people not doing it, that,
blindly, believe that to be true?
It became about judgment,
it became about mindset.
And, that's what I'm trying to tackle,
and, that's what I'm trying
to give to you, this morning.
I'm trying to figure out, like who, what.
It's why I talk so much about patience,
I used to think it was
patience and, it is,
because every 22 year
old wants a tomorrow.
Every 40 year old wants a tomorrow,
we just lack patience, because
unfortunately, so many
people here, and I mean this,
so, this is not tough love
or razz, it's just the truth.
So many people here went
into cryptocurrency,
or cannabis, or social media
'cause they thought they were
gonna make the money faster.
People lose 'cause they think,
it's gonna happen fast, when life is long.
And, so, I've been spending
a lot of time on this,
just watching behaviors, who's winning?
Who's winning is the person
that likes what they do.
It's true, like how many
more fucking millionaires
do I have to hang out with,
that are gonna take their life
or, are in deep depression
or doing drugs and alcohol
to deal with the pain, 'cause
making 2.3 million dollars
a year brings them zero fucking happiness.
And, how many people do
I have to hang out with
that make 87 thousand a year
that sells Smurf T-shirts
on the internet, and, love fucking life?
You like that one?
(audience cheering)
It's good, you gonna
sell some smurf T-shirts?
Go with Alf, open market.
(audience laughing)
Shit's getting very clear for me,
maybe it's 'cause I'm getting older, now,
but, shit's getting very clear to me.
It's pattern recognition,
life is very basic.
We make it, unbelievably,
complicated, we're,
unbelievably, products of
the DNA, and, the parents,
and, the environment we
grew up on, and, we have to,
really, understand that so we know how
to navigate the next step.
People lack the ability to
put their life in perspective.
I've been pushing people,
lately, who are 43 year old
entrepreneurs, sending me emails
and, they have a six year old child,
they love their business,
they're killing it.
Things are going great,
and, my advice to them
is to slow down, and, take
the next 12 years, and,
actually, because they're
telling me what they know about
themselves is, if they go to little Ricky
and little Janet's
softball games and recitals
and, if they hang out with them
and, play Wii with them all day that
that's what's gonna make them happy.
And, then, they think they
are sending me an email
because I'm business guy
and I'm gonna tell them
that's wrong are you out
of your fucking mind?
You need to be happy and
if you're self aware enough
to know that at 43 years old,
you have six year old kids that you want
to spend the next 12 years
taking the foot off the pedal,
so, you can allocate time
to watch those kids grow.
I've got tremendous news
for you, you're just gonna
be 55 and, that baby,
when they go to college,
and, they're not gonna
want to talk to you anyway
and, you're gonna be able to go all in.
(audience clapping)
Do you know how liberating it is
when people understand
how young 59 years old is?
Do you know how many people
think they're supposed
to have their life figured
out at 18, 22 and 30?
When the parents that are putting pressure
on them to figure out their lives,
don't have their lives figured out?
Oh, I like that one.
(audience laughing)
How the fuck are you supposed
to have your whole life
figured out at 28 years old?
It's ludicrous.
We have such interesting macro thesises,
in our society, that are crippling people.
And, the reason there's so much anxiety
in the system, now, is we're all living
our lives in public
forums, and now taking on
more judgment, not less.
I don't hear any of you.
Let me say it one more time.
How many people here fuck with my content
and they love it.
Let me hear you.
(audience cheering)
Can't hear you.
(audience screaming)
(audience laughing)
Let me say it one more time.
For all the people here,
who think I fucking walk
on water, I'm the best,
I'm such a great dude,
I can't fucking hear you.
Let me explain why.
(audience member screaming)
Not you, bro.
(audience laughing)
Let me explain to you
why I can't hear you,
because I have no interest on
getting high on my own supply.
(audience clapping)
The reason I can't hear you,
is the same reason that
I can't hear the person
that leaves a comment that
says I'm a snake oil salesman
or, my cursing is
inappropriate, or, I suck
or I'm gonna burn out, or whatever else,
I can't hear that fuck face, either.
(audience laughing)
And, when over the next
50 years of my life,
I figure out how to
produce more communications
to help you not hear it, either,
that is when I will start
having more significant impact,
because when you don't hear anything,
and, I don't mean from just fattypants63.
I mean from your dad, I
mean from your spouse.
When you, my friends, in Phoenix,
on a Wednesday, going in to 2019,
when you stop hearing things,
shit gets remarkable.
(audience cheering)
How many people here
have been following me
for more then four
years, raise your hands.
Raise it high, please.
So, for the ones that raised their hands,
you know something about me.
You know that I'm not interested
in being a motivational speaker.
You know that four years ago
I was making much more tactical,
jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Like, I didn't want to
rah rah what I just did
for the last ten minutes.
I don't want to be that
guy, I have it in me,
I live it, I believe it.
but, I don't want to go on stage
and rah rah and have
claps, I don't, I don't.
The reason I'm back here,
is what I want is for you
to post 19 pieces of content, tomorrow,
on LinkedIn, Facebook,
YouTube, and Instagram,
because it will answer the fucking things
that are running through
your head, right now.
The problem was, after I was done doing
that for three or four years,
and, you would look me dead in the face
in a meeting, let alone in a stage,
and, be like I get it, I understand it,
but, you still weren't doing it,
I'm like, I don't get
it; and, then I got it.
This is such a big deal.
Like you're literally,
literally not posting shit,
or, more interestingly,
you are posting shit
because you are now all the PR agents
of yourselves, on social media.
It's really great to take
a beautiful family picture,
picking fucking pumpkins.
(audience laughing)
Meanwhile, shit's not going well.
It's, really, awesome to post a picture
on a private plane
saying you're killing it,
when your company's about
to go out of business.
We are posturing, my
friends, we are posturing
for other peoples' opinions.
Your lack of action is
exposing your insecurity.
If you're educated, if you follow me,
and, you are not posting 10 to 15 pieces
of content a day, your actions
are exposing your insecurity.
The end.
So, I come on the stage
this morning with heat
and passion, because A.
I'm fucking well rested.
(audience laughing)
Thanksgiving was a good rest, for me.
But, B. I come here
because I'm just trying
to fucking get one person in this room
who's looking at me right now and saying,
that's, actually, the truth.
- [Audience Member] Yep.
- I appreciate that.
I am not posting because
my hair is receding
and, I'm insecure about it.
(audience chuckling)
I'm being serious, I'm
being dead fucking serious.
I am not posting because I'm up 13 pounds,
and, I don't want to hear
the fucking comments.
I'm not posting because all
my high school friends seem
to be doing better than me--they're not.
You're hearing too much.
You're putting other peoples' opinions
at a higher place than your own happiness.
It blows my face away
and, I kiss the ground
that my parents walk on,
for creating an infrastructure
that didn't create that for me.
You know why?
And, this is for for all
the-- how many people here
are parents of six to 18
year olds, raise your hands?
This one's for you.
Let me tell you why it
didn't happen to me.
Because from six to 18, the
world told me I was a loser.
Because I played a bunch
of sports in the backyard
and, leagues and we didn't
give 8th place trophies
when you fucking lost.
(audience cheering)
You know why else I can't hear you?
Because I grew up in an environment
where every fucking teacher
looked me, dead in the face,
and, told me I was gonna be a loser
'cause I got an F in science.
I don't give a fuck about Jupiter, dick.
(audience laughing)
Do you know why I could post everyday
and, not care about what you have to say?
Because every friend I had,
parents, in high school,
when they ask me what college
I was going to, when I said,
Mount Ida College, they
snickered in my fucking face.
Losing is great.
(audience applauding)
I got lucky, I was born in
a shitty fucking place
called the Soviet Union.
I got luckier by getting the fuck out
and, coming to America,
the greatest fucking
country, in the world.
(audience cheering)
And, being raised by a mother
who would clap me up just like
that if I opened the door for a old lady,
but, when I asked her for a Nintendo game,
she looked me dead in the face and said,
"Go fucking figure it out, and,
buy it for yourself, dick."
(audience laughing)
You want to know why most
people aren't winning
and, aren't happy?
It's 'cause you're fucking entitled.
(audience cheering)
People think they're owed something.
I know, brother, people for some reason,
I watch it every day.
Nobody owes you shit.
Figure it the fuck out.
(audience agreeing)
And, I'm gonna give you
the two basic principles,
they're so fucking simple, it scares
the shit out of me.
Number one, this, you have
to learn how to do this,
please, my friends.
I've never done this before,
it's weird, I can't hear anything.
Please,
(audience laughing)
I didn't even hear you guys laughing,
but, I can see you doing it,
this is really fucking fun.
Actually, I might give a
whole keynote like this,
this is fucking freaky as shit.
(audience laughing)
I see you, I see you, clappy hands
Listen to me, clappy hands, this.
This is the secret to my happiness.
I'm so fucking happy because I can't hear
a fucking thing, do you understand?
(audience agreeing)
When you get there, you start doing
because you're not scared
that you hired somebody
and, they didn't work out.
You just fire them, you don't care
that your other co-workers
think that you made a mistake.
You start doing and talking
shit that it's all gonna
be great because if it
is, awesome, you're cool,
and if it's not, you don't care, anyway,
because as soon as somebody brings it up--
do you know why I had the
audacity to make a sneaker,
do you know why I did it?
Let me tell you why, because
I can't hear anything.
If it worked, and, thank
God, it did, I look good.
If it didn't, my seven
best friends would make fun
of me for the rest of my life.
And, that was good too.
I was looking forward to my roast at 83
when Robbie Turnick was like,
"And, remember that time you"
"thought you could sell a sneaker?"
"You're a real fucking dick."
(audience laughing)
Learn to eliminate judgment.
Learn to realize the reason
you're not posting everyday,
800 times a day, is 'cause you're worried
about what people are going to say.
My friends, high school is over.
Start acting like it.
(audience cheering)
'Cause you're stuck in high school.
I'm serious, it took me a long time.
It took me a long time to figure out why
this isn't working for me.
I'm like right, if I was
able to navigate high school
and, not fall into peer pressure,
that's the hardest part, this is easy.
I just need you to create content.
I need you to figure out how to do it.
I could care less what all
7,000 of you said to me
of what you're trying to do.
The answer is content.
I'm being dead serious.
It's where our world is living.
News alert, this is now real life,
this is fake, you don't
like it, tough shit.
Technology doesn't care
about your feelings
about the old days.
Leave It to Beaver is fucking dead.
(audience laughing)
Sorry.
(audience giggling)
Abraham Lincoln died, too.
In a weird way, actually.
But, the point of that
analogy is shit changes.
We have to figure out this.
I don't care if you're 18 or 81,
I don't want to hear
that you didn't grow up
with it, you didn't grow up
driving, you figured it out.
You have something called
Google and YouTube.
Google is you like to read,
YouTube if you're more visual.
You type in every question you have.
How does a lawyer make
content on LinkedIn?
Thousands of results.
How does a pharmacist grow
her brand on Instagram?
Thousands of results.
It's also free.
It's 2019, act like it, Phoenix.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Thank you.